chalus tout le monde aujourd'hui je vous
propose une émission un peu différente
on va pas parler de jeux vidéo on va
parler d'une émission une émission que
vous avez tous vu au moins une fois et
peut-être parmentier et il est probable
que vous sentirez un peu mal à l'aise en
regardant cette vidéo mais moi aussi je
me suis senti un peu mal à l'aise en la
faisant je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez mais au milieu des dragon ball
des radins denis des cités d'or et
amusante joyeuse qui faisait passer de
bons moments il y avait une horreur une
émission conçue par satan en personne et
il y avait que deux types de réactions
face à une émission comme ça c'était ou
à leurs 2 ap quelques minutes sur le
télé achat pour ne pas la regarder
ou alors de la regarder et d'être à la
fois fasciné et effrayé
ça passait à l'époque sur récré a2 ça a
commencé en 1983 et ça a continué bien
après que dorothée soit parti créé le
célèbre club dorothée sur la une s'est
un peu embrouillé dans mon esprit je ne
tiens plus exactement quand j'ai
commencé à le regarder
parce que comme beaucoup d'entre vous
j'ai préféré de chasse et de ma mémoire
j'en ai fait des cauchemars c'était
flippant malsain tordu bizarre dans tous
les sens du terme
je veux parler de l'émission 666 sorti
tout droit des enfers je veux parler de
tes les chiens
[Musique]
mon dieu rit que ça [ __ ] tu es de
sortir d'un épisode je sais par un
dragon ball de la bande à picsou et d'un
coutances au générique on dirait qu'il a
été composée par un dépressif alcoolique
j'ai bien envie de sauter du toit de
m'éclater en bas
c'est un truc de fou quand même
t'imagines à l'époque tu te tapes à la
suite rémi sans famille presse à sarah
et et les chats c'est bon je dire pays
telle antidépresseurs après ça salut
salut
j'étais certain que ça arriverait un
jour eh bien si fait quoi qu'est ce qui
est fait ils ont mis la rue à sens
unique
et maintenant on s'en fout notamment
déblayé tous les émissions sont
constellés de ce genre de jeu délire
décalé bizarre il fonctionne en rire la
mairie
et puisque les jours se suivent sans
améliorer je préfère regarder en arrière
faste dans le temps même le futur était
mieux quand il est là qui valente
atteint elle me dites pas que c'est pas
perché contre 15 le concept de
l'émission c'est plus une série parodie
le journal télévisé des adultes le ton y
est assez critique sur la télévision la
course à l'audience
les parachutages vous croyez vraiment
qu'un gosse qui regardent récré a2 est
sensible à l'autocritique sur la course
à l'audience des médias mais je crois
que le pire de tous étaient les invités
qui venait ponctuer les missions
[ __ ] c'était la foire aux monstres si
un jour on me demande de faire une
maison hantée je vous jure que je
reprends tous les objets qu'ils avaient
tenté les chats le ballet qui a un
accent marseillais les gluons les genres
de petites rues vivant qui venu dans la
nourriture commandes
l'aspirateur le téléphone c'est pour toi
curus [ __ ] le téléphone regardez le
titre
on dirait une tête de foetus écrasé
qu'on aura encastré de force dans un
téléphone y avait aussi des interludes
pub le singe vers mi temps on s'est
regardé le me regarde avec ses yeux
ronds la kiné ce qu'ils ne regardent pas
ce sont des psychopathes
à chaque émission je m'attendais à ce
qu'ils soient pris d'un accès de rage
qui lie la serre et décapité le chat ou
qui sortent de l'écran pour venir le but
à moi siraj nuls le cirage des vice
consul
[Musique]
mais c'est pour les chaussures plus
alors y'a pas de pub aujourd'hui il ya
des objets franchement dans cette
émission ils sont mais carrément mais
carrément gorge
vous vous souvenez du micro de groucha
c'était une espèce de tête de bébé
arraché sur laquelle il avait escroqué
une des oreilles pour parler devant le
fer à repasser
incroyable regarder ça replacer cela
dans le contexte de l'enfance on dirait
qu'ils ont arraché la peau d'un type et
qu'ils l'ont collé dessus et qu'ils
utilisent un espèce de sort mal et
fiable pour que le mec evans pas la
chance de mourir
laissez moi mourir s'il vous plaît
maintenant
[Musique]
soleil et ton père tu frimas un coup
ciel à ceux qui volent d'accueil
légumes au [ __ ] voilà autre chose que
j'avais réussi avec facilement et moi
regarde et regarde il entre dans la
maison comme bühler psychopathe
c'est horrible envie lui arrache les
entrailles elle est un autre
[Musique]
non la chambre de bébé le petit chou est
en danger la terrible mons casque et à
l'audace de l'attaqué les carottes sont
cuites
non c'est peut-être pour ça je suis a
tendance à fermer les fenêtres tumeur
mais non n'empêche qu'il ya vraiment que
dante et les chats que vous pouvez voir
une citrouille qui essayent de violer
une mouche j'aime beaucoup comment ils
baissent les bras à la fin regardez
c'est à ces genres il y en a marre de
ces conneries mais je me casse
c'est vraiment trop malsain moi j'arrête
ici au bon sinon je profite de cette
vidéo un peu spéciale pour remercier
tous les abonnés qui nous ont suivi
jusqu'ici
sachez je tiens compte de tous vos
commentaires j'écoute toutes vos
critiques et j'écoute toutes vos
suggestions de jeu d'ailleurs j'en
profite pour vous parler d'un projet de
site qui va regrouper tous les testeurs
français les plus connus sur près stable
bouton point fr je vous invite à y aller
et sur ce je laisse le mot de la fin à
gros chat salut à demain si on veut bien
je lis tous les commentaires et j'écoute
toutes vos critiques et j'en tiens
compte
j'en profite aussi pour vous tient
compte de tous vos critiques je tiens
compte de tous vos commentaires et je
chante sans compter pour remercier tous
les abonnés qui nous ont suivis et qui
nous soutiennent jusque là sachez que
c'est que le début de cette aventure
formidable vraiment trop malsain moi
j'arrête ici
[Musique]
des eaux spécial pour vous remercier
vous tous les abonnés qui nous
soutenaient une rechute
sur ce je laisse le mot de la fin
arusha à la prochaine c'était nul à ch
c'était bidon comme s'il me trouve
[Musique]